hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the end of friedrich nietzsche's essay
on truth and lying in an extra moral
sense is taken up by sketching out this
clash between the what he calls the
intuitive person and the rational person
and he sees this as a particularly
modern late modern conflict something
that we are facing in our own time and
the entire you know section - it's a
short section bringing this to a close
is concerned with this now Nietzsche
begins by talking about the human drive
or or desires how it's also translated
here fundamental desire plebe in German
has this you know in sort of impulse
pushing forward driving forward it's not
just desiring in a sort of static way of
oh I hope I get something it's just
moving out towards it so this he says
this is a basic drive to form metaphors
that's a fundamental desire in human
beings we we cannot really eliminate
this even though we live in highly
rationalized societies you know if they
strike us as irrational the very
criterion by which we talk about their
irrationality is often hyper-rational
from Nietzsche's perspective it's done
with concepts we expect things to remain
the same we talk about science and laws
of nature we have forgotten the
metaphors that we have used to create an
entire world and he talks about living
in a kind of prison that which is of our
own construction a prison of concepts of
schemata even despite that this drive
for metaphor pushes through it can't be
eliminated so long as there are human
beings there's always going to be
somebody messing around with that
Nietzsche is in a certain respect the
the admirer and the advocate of the one
who subverts
who goes beyond the the rules and the
hierarchies and the structures and
doesn't necessarily get rid of them but
imposes new forms as well so he says
that you know science is working at this
what he calls great columbarium of the
concept the sepulcher of intuition where
it's gonna die right
forever constructing higher and higher
levels and yet intuition and myth art
metaphor all of those things are gonna
still be with us sometimes they'll be
repressed sometimes they'll be dismissed
belittled even turned into as we might
see in our own time commodities but
they're always going to escape this what
he called Columbarium or his his prison
house as he's called it in other places
so he says this drive cannot be
discounted for one moment because that
would amount to ignoring man himself now
does he mean by this that you know in
the beginning we had the metaphor and
then we developed something better we're
sort of you know this this upward
movement throughout history developing
further and further and further that is
not what nietzsche is saying here he's
talking about the capacity to break
through at any given time so he says
that we're not you know restrained by
the fact that out of our diminished
product the concepts regular and rigid
worlds built up for him as a prison
fortress yet this drive seeks a new
province for its activities in a
different riverbed is the metaphor here
we could say it finds new outlets it
finds new ways to express itself and not
just to express itself is something
that's you know bet in the background
and it has to find a nice way to make
everyone know what's going on know
expressing itself in this case having an
outlet in this case means where it can
develop itself
where
can be active so where does it do that
in myth and an art now what is Nietzsche
talking about here historically we've
said well we're talking about our own
time he's going to shoot this backwards
into ancient Greece as well myth is
something that comes on the scene and so
does epic poetry art when you've got
this entire structure of schemata that's
set out when you have a rational you
know set of associations metaphors that
were originally metaphors vivid but have
lost that that vivacity and have now
become merely you know structures or
schemas or ways in which we share a
common language that will that happen
very early on and yet at every point
myth and art were there to turn things
topsy-turvy and it continues on in the
present today we have myths ourselves
here and now we have things that we
believe in and get all jazzed up about
and find meaning in it when when we
don't find it in this this rational
structure and art is still taking place
not necessarily in the art schools not
necessarily in the art museums although
you can go to those and certainly see
some cool things but perhaps in other
ways as well so he goes on and he says
this drive constantly confuses the
categories and cells of the concepts by
presenting new transferences metaphors
and medon ins constantly showing the
desire to shape the existing world of
the wide awake person to be variegated
ly irregular and disinterestedly
incoherent exciting and eternally new
like the world of dreams well what do
you think it is when we watch
movie and we're like oh my god that's an
experience not just uh yeah action movie
I know what's going to happen over there
rom-com know what's gonna happen over
there you know I've got the code down
but when something new happens when we
listen to music and we are surprised by
the reinterpretation of old motifs or
when we listen again to the old music
with new years all of these are
possibilities for us when we write
poetry to each other and we're not just
doing it to impress each other in cafes
or you know to satisfy a requirement in
a class but we're trying to forge new
meaning this is what Nietzsche is
talking about here so there's a desire
to reshape to subvert to confuse to
blend together to rework to make
irregular to reintroduce effectivity
desire all of these sorts of things that
stand a risk of being lost so he goes on
and he says we have this unconquered
bull tendency to let ourselves be
deceived and he is as if in enchanted
with happiness when the rhapsode s
the rhapsode us the rhapsode astir of
the traditional poetry you would go from
city to city and interpret homer you
would you would say the rhymes right
because homer was of course poetry and
then you might explain it and interpret
it and you would put your own spin on it
likewise that the the actors in the play
and the tragedies and comedies and satyr
plays are reinterpreting things for us
who are the rap satis of our time that
is a question that we have to think
about who is the person that we would
identify with what nietzsche is talking
about here is happening in ancient
Greece and in in Rome and now notice
that he's talking here also about
another Keith
that we began looking at early on in the
essay this dis simulation and deception
that takes place that Nietzsche sees as
at the very root of the human intellect
it's also involved in art and the
question is not whether we're going to
have dis simulation but what kind is it
going to be is it going to be dis
simulation that conceals from us that
dis simulation is taking place or is it
going to be more honest is it going to
be engaging in the dis simulation and
inviting us to join in at least by
apprehending it and responding to it he
talks about here as long as it can
deceive without harm the intellect that
master of deception is free and released
from its usual servile tasks and that is
what it celebrates it's Saturnalia
Saturnalia is a holiday where everything
is turned upside down and you have a
great time he says never is it more
luxuriant richer prouder more skillful
and bold the poet the interpreter of the
poet the rhapsodies is able to take the
the human intellect and turn it to this
this you know capacity that it has for
creating metaphors for reworking
metaphors for coming up with something
new and he does that and people are
pleased by it now they're pleased by it
because it's art and and art in a
certain sense is you know like a leisure
time activity it's it's not real life
it's it's something different
but it can start to absorb more and more
and more so he goes on and he tells us
look everything contains dis simulation
it's it's whether we have the dis
simulation involved in art or we have
the disk simulation involved in the
ghostly schemata of abstractions the the
prison-house the Columbarium
and here he starts talking about how the
artist and a certain kind of person
you know in our own time takes guidance
no longer from concepts as such but from
intuitions and this requires a little
bit of explanation when we see this word
intuition we often associate it with
like Oh a gut feeling or you know I put
my intellect aside and I just go with
you know my intuition intuitions here is
in the plural one has intuitions and
they could be at war with each other
they may require some thinking out they
have to be if not reconciled at least
brought into some sort of dynamic
tension with each other so that they can
occupy the stage at the same time and
Nietzsche is telling us that that this
is something that was going on with in
ancient Greece of which are the people
that he looks to quite a lot he says
there are ages in which the rational man
and the intuitive man stand by side by
side one in fear of intuition the
rational person fears intuition it's
irrational
it's ungrounded it's unsafe how do I
know that it's actually going to work
out the way it's supposed to work out
you know it doesn't fit the code the
intuitive person he says with mockery of
that for abstraction both he says desire
to master life one by managing to meet
his main needs with foresight prudence
reliability the other as the over joyous
hero so we have two different responses
to the problem of life both of them
actually do use the intellect but one of
them uses the intellect in a
metaphorical way in a productive way the
other uses it in a way that's sort of
laid out in advance and you can you can
proceed along with you know
crunching new numbers you could say
generating new code replicating the same
and the same
the same and isn't that boring
ultimately the the side of interests for
Nietzsche lies with the intuitive person
notice that both of them are engaged in
dis simulation both of them are changing
the world in a certain way both of them
are doing so in an anthropomorphic way
the question is which of them is going
to prevail in in modernity in which
we're going our selves to align with he
talks here about the Greeks and again he
says that they could do a playing with
serious matter when the man guided by
concepts and abstractions merely Ward's
off misfortune without extracting
happiness for himself then the intuitive
man standing in the midst of culture in
addition to warding off harm reaps from
his intuitions a continuously streaming
clarification cheerfulness Redemption
you see which side Nietzsche is on the
side of the intuitive person very
clearly he contrasts to that what he
actually calls the stoic who's a
lowercase person who is seeking you know
honesty truth freedom from delusions and
protection from enthralling seizures
Nietzsche is saying that's never really
going to be possible the way forward for
Nietzsche is with the intuitive person
who works by way of metaphor and through
myth and art
you